[Musique]
oh
mais voilà rom voix
bon voilà
ben dites donc il en faut faire une
grimpette pour venir vous voir on est où
ici à quelle altitude
très élevée à
970 net et bien c'est un des points
culminants du plateau de millevaches qui
s'étend tout autour de nous nous sommes
sur le plateau lui lâche qui par
l'épisode de l'art de la commune dans le
jeu et ça va jusqu'à la loyère la
macreuse dites moi il ya longtemps que
vous vivez sur ce plateau de millevaches
ma foi oui j'ai basé à busnes toute ma
vie et vous avez gardé des moutons toute
votre existence
[Musique]
c'est parce que mon vrai métier garder
longtemps oui j'ai bien été quelques
temps à paris mais la ville n'a pas plu
lait n'était pas pu tandis qu'ici vous
vous portiez ici je suis allée frais et
je ferai mon panorama je vois aller mon
domaine les monts du cantal et les
confins des monédières et vous dites moi
mais vous êtes un homme gatti est ce que
vous avez été heureux dans votre vie
monsieur
et en bonne santé toujours
vous n'avez jamais été malade mais ma
femme dites moi vous ne vous êtes jamais
mariés eh bien non comprenez bien quand
on est berger grand palais le temps
faire l'amour et vous
vous avez le temps de penser est de
penser aussi à quoi pensiez-vous tout
seul dans vos montagnes
jeu
et vous chantez quelquefois à 21 20 ans
je lance une petite romance et bien vous
voudriez pas chanter un peu plus loin
que jamais et bien alors faites moi
plaisir chanter moi quelque chose oui
chalon
pour tous
sous les lustres de
tout mon coeur
[Musique]
le cas le plus bas
l'amour tout je trouve toujours
au bras d'un chef qui est un jeu et
laure je
fais
la chapelle
ont fait le bonheur des jeux
enfin moi
les yeux et bien dites moi mais c'est
parfait seulement vous chante une
chanson lakitu chansons parisiennes et
vous n'aimiez pas paris vous sentez une
chanson d'amour et vous ne vous êtes
jamais mariés c'est pas curieux ça que
je voulais c'était vous distraire et
bien vous m'avez distrait je vous en
remercie la
tatin
[Musique]
je vois le grand chalon une veine moment
là
voilà près de rennes
[Musique]
aulas
où